-Performing his new single,
"Willing to Trust,"
from his new album,
"Entergalactic,"
give it up for Kid Cudi,
featuring Ty Dolla $ign.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ Scatting ]
♪ It's the day
I've been waitin' for ♪
♪ And I'm settin' the scene ♪
♪ Your touch paralyzes me
in the mornin' ♪
♪ I don't want you to go ♪
♪ Sincerely yours,
forevermore ♪
♪ And teach me what you know ♪
♪ And I count on you,
show me something new, honey ♪
♪ Mmm-mmm ♪
♪ Oh, take control of me ♪
♪ Ohh, take control of me ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ I been ♪
♪ Willing to trust someone ♪
♪ And I've, I, been, been ♪
♪ Oh, I've, I, been, been ♪
♪ Willing to trust someone ♪
♪ And I've, I, been, been ♪
♪ If we ain't got trust,
we ain't got nothin' ♪
♪ Is this really love,
what it's becomin'? ♪
♪ Funny how we turned
into somethin' ♪
♪ Said you wasn't even lookin'
for a boyfriend ♪
♪ Don't need new friends,
that...so confusin' ♪
♪ Left your ex, thought
you'd never trust a man again ♪
♪ Don't take it out on me, nah ♪
♪ Don't do me dirty,
let's make this worth it ♪
♪ I been ♪
♪ Willing to trust someone ♪
♪ And I've, I, been, been ♪
♪ Oh, I've, I, been, been ♪
♪ Willing to trust someone ♪
♪ And I've, I, been, been ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Rhythmic clapping ]
♪♪
♪ Yeah, oh-oh ♪
♪ No, no ♪
♪♪
[ Scatting ]
♪ I got you, don't worry, love ♪
♪ Oh, hold on me ♪
♪ Oh, just lay with me ♪
♪ I got you, don't worry, love ♪
♪ Oh, you're so sweet ♪
♪ Right here is where
I'll be, babe ♪
♪ I got you, don't worry, love ♪
♪ Oh, hold on me ♪
♪ Oh-oh, just lay with me ♪
♪ I got you, don't worry, love ♪
♪ Oh, you're so sweet ♪
♪ Right here is where
I'll be, babe ♪
♪ I got you, don't worry, love ♪
♪ All this time,
I thought I'd never find ♪
♪ I got you, don't worry, love ♪
♪ Some girl
that I can call mine ♪
♪ I got you, don't worry, love ♪
♪ Oh, so silly on me ♪
♪ Oh, just hold on me ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jimmy: Oh! Come on, now!